B ramaswami is against cancel culture
even for the Harvard University students
who made idiotic comments about
Israel good for him he is right now many
Harvard students signed an open letter
blaming the Hamas terrorist attacks
entirely on Israel people were right to
criticize them some pundits have gone
even further calling for employers to
refuse to hire them quote it's not
productive for companies to blackless
kids for being members of student groups
that make dumb political statements on
campus says ramaswami colleges are
spaces for students to experiment with
ideas and sometimes kids join clubs that
endorse boneheaded wrong ideas ramas
Swami is correct on all counts everyone
has said or done something they
eventually come to regret and thanks to
the social media era our worst moments
are often preserved on the internet for
all time we ought to extend more
forgiveness more charity more compassion
to people who find themselves in trouble
if you join an angry mob it can always
turn on you